hey guys I'm Greg now I'm John so we did
a review of the guardians of galaxy vol
2 non-spoiler review this will be our
spoiler talk we wrote down a couple of
notes of the specific scenes we'd like
to touch on or moments in the film and
if you want to hear our overall opinion
you can go check out the main review on
the main chain yeah are not so and the
non-spoiler one what we do mention is
that we we like the film it's enjoyable
it's entertaining however I think for
the most part Jon and I did leave
disappointed like there's uneven fish
it's an uneven film that comedies really
out of place a lot of the time yeah and
that's and but you know one thing we
were struggling with it was like how to
really explain a lot of why we're
disappointed without going into detail
and spoilers so that's what this video
is for but we'll start off with some
we'll start off with some good things
that I really liked like specific scenes
are they liking this film the highlight
of the film for me was the way yondu was
handled so Michael Rooker is like bad
guy like the best F being a bad guy we
all you know interested yeah we know
that and if there's one thing that you
know one thing that Walking Dead did
really well with Michael Rooker was
taking a character who was just you know
elsewhere restricted mode yeah hateable
into he was a good guy after all
oh you know or at least there was
something in the editors still you know
he's not just an evil guy yeah and this
movie does it in a way where it's not
it's not forced it's not Jason Statham
in Fast and Furious it's going on cuz
this movie when they start winning when
you first see yondu it starts off with
him looking like rather depressed and
lonely and you can see that his crew of
though or the Ravagers ravages yeah
Ravagers are they're starting to doubt
their leader lately it's been their soft
losing faith in their leader and when
his when the Ravagers do eventually turn
on him the way his character progresses
how he gets thrown in prison jail and
what what in the film for me really
start a click is when yondu and rockets
start to bond with each other yes in
that prison cell and how they have fun
with baby Groot I really liked a lot
work they keep having baby crew try to
retrieve this because it is his Finn
gets shot off and they have a prototype
in that they need baby Groot to go words
but retrieve but he just doesn't
understand but he's looking forward and
that was a funny segment but it's
specifically the dialogue and the
interaction the relationship that
develops would yondu and rocket racoon
that was the highlight of the film for
me well that's what rocket two started
to really become a real part of the
movie for me because up until that point
he's just kind of yeah rocket - yeah
rocket series not even that funny in
this movie yeah I mean I don't recall a
single joke that he made that was like
truly like I was never the first one I'm
like a drag it was the funniest boy yeah
but here am i I mean yes joke said I
think I laughed at but nothing that's
like truly stand out joke to me you know
and again like this is one of the things
I thought was the most cool and clever
about this yeah movie is is the pairing
of different characters together and and
yeah
yondu is kind of the the main plot of
the movie to me yeah it is and and the
way and that whole sequence - when they
owned he gets his fin and he starts
using the arrow that was an interesting
scene for me because I'm like this is
pretty cool this is yoga killing
everyone but then it also kind of went
borderline ooh very violent for me yes
like this is a massacre this is a
massacre and rocket and yondu are loving
it that's that was the part of it that
seemed like kind of a it's in tune with
the character but so many people are
being murdered and a lot of them are
human beings it's as you think about
what we're
doing here it's like on the one hand
just as like a fan of cool outlaw
characters you know for that the edge
immorality of that I'm like yeah cool
this is awesome in like a pg-13 Marvel
flick that you might probably take your
kids to up a little bit like killing
guys with an errand with Jo arrow you
know an empress I feel like an arrow is
something more felt than a laser gun or
something like that shooting them you
know yeah I don't know I mean it's
fantasy and whatever but just that
argument doesn't really work that well
for me of like oh it's pg-13 cuz there's
no blood I'm like yeah but still a bunch
of dudes have died and they're kind of
like maniacally laughing about it yeah
they're regularly killers in that scene
they're just what about killer simple
timid rocket or killers yeah and so I
mean it's it's still a cool scene it's a
little bit silent because I mean that
whole stuff with the Ravagers is one of
the darker elements of the film yeah
like and one thing I sent an onslaught
was I like the darker elements here like
I appreciated that scene a lot where you
see that they're putting the Ravagers
that were siding with yondu and just
releasing them into space to get frozen
and die then they show that reveal shot
of all them floating in space and that
was a great sequence to me honestly
now that scene really hit for me as a
dark moment in the film I thought it was
very effective well that was the moment
that actually carried some real dread
and and just for me as a horror fan like
that was a nice nerd moment of like yeah
James Gunn is still drawing from that
part of his palette you know and I like
when the film gets really weird - one of
my favorite scenes in the movie is when
I don't know the technical terms we were
using they do they they're jumping
across the galaxy and they're I guess
you do like 50 jumps at a time and
instead they do 700 like they have this
really trippy sequence where like time
and like space-time is bending their
faces or my eyes are coming out huge
yeah yeah that was a really fun sequence
and I remember laughing out loud a lot
during that moment I think the whole
crowd was digging that a lot and it's
cool and yeah I appreciate the weirdness
of the film and it's funny because like
I kind of wanted
or of that CNN it was a weird place for
this movie to be like no we're gonna
play a restraint we're not gonna do that
whole term yeah
yeah absolutely cause like on the heels
of stuff like Doctor Strange and some of
the other stuff I'm like yeah let's do a
true P scene like cuz I like those out
of Marvel but okay we might not stay a
complete you know linear order here of
how the scenes play out but one thing I
said the non-spoiler was how I felt the
attention to detail in terms of
character and and any like just stuff in
scenes was not as strong in this one
yeah that would pull me out of the film
and and have me say stuff that might
sound nitpicky but it's not I don't
really consider nitpicky when I feel
like the first Guardians just wouldn't
do some stuff I think about nitpicks is
that if something pulls you out of a
movie then now you're in this place of
thinking now you're in this like oh I'm
back in the chair and now I got a look
at this because somebody hold me out you
know because when you first see the
Guardians there's that great scene they
see in the trailer where they're finding
that giant like octopus squid thing yeah
and I like the way that how a lot of
that was handled how a lot of it is just
you're focusing on Groot and then it and
your the credits are rolling and
everything and and honestly it's in the
back yeah yeah exactly and then
eventually it comes more into focus the
sovereign characters the gold people
he's seen the trailers when when Rockets
stole the the batteries yeah if you
picked if you've seen the movie Rockets
decision of stealing the batteries
played a major problem for every one of
our main characters as in terms of
detail they probably said they move a
little weird subplot because it doesn't
seem like it's gonna be significant but
it she's coming back he's coming back it
was kind of frustrating to me how the
film was trying to portray the sovereign
characters as if they're antagonists as
if they're bad guy yeah like there's the
if you pay attention
they're shooting their scenes like
they're bad guys when you not they had a
deal they gave them nebula in exchange
for taking out that creature everything
was good about these guys and then
rocket made a dumb decision
to steal their batteries well didn't
they
they like bring back some battery like
did somebody else steal batteries they
brought them back and they're rock and
decides to steal they like three yeah
like that's that whole thing really
makes it like this movie treats it as
though just anyone who's against the
Guardians is a villain and and I
couldn't let that go I was like oh this
is the Guardians and I would be pissed
off too in terms of little details
there's this moment where that are
walking out there's all that all of them
are lined up and all their look all the
both a sovereign people are just
watching the Guardians leave and then
rocket opens his back his bag where the
batteries are glowing and Drax look
sound stars laughing so loud about how
they took the batteries I was thinking
like we call it an epic but one of them
would have noticed that rocket had
batteries like it was it was too much
employing sight for me and rockin and
his re and the reaction for Drax to not
keep it subtle was I I don't know
there's just something about that moment
that was not fitting for me would Drax
just just laugh at Dyea like I always
felt like Drax at least had some sense
and exactly what starts to lose me too
was the whole sequence where I thought
the sequence was neat where all the
people in the sovereign are you know you
controlling their ships from back at
their home base and they're fighting
they're going after the Guardians I was
funny my problem with the scene though
was there felt no real sense of danger
and the Guardians didn't really feel
like they were it just didn't feel like
there was any really dink real danger
and in terms of attention to detail
there's these comedy moments where
star-lord and rocket racoon are having
ego battle over who should be
controlling the ship and whatnot but
there's the past this there's but in the
moment that ghosts are going to his
asteroid field whereas where it's just
appear out of nowhere and there are
times where I'm like they're just
looking at each other right now and
arguing when they're going through an
asteroid field and it would bother me
how their their eyes are fixated on each
other as our swerve I'm like no they
would have crashed they would have
crashed yes they're not and
sit on the goal of surviving this I
thought that sneak gonna been handled
better just just in general like I don't
necessarily think that they shouldn't
have had them are you yeah I am the best
pilot I know I'm the best pilot cool but
the scene didn't seem to have a care for
the balance of the danger and comedy it
seemed to care more about it being a
funny scene
yeah entertaining visuals going on there
yeah and it is that it's like if you
look out the window it looks like this
is a pretty hard way to navigate this
and I just don't believe anymore that if
you guys are like stealing the controls
back and forth that this lights gonna go
well yeah yeah I completely agree with
that the whole like even though like
they're so good even though they were
both battling and still got done just
didn't really she caught like a hundred
ships shooting at them while going
through an asteroid really the best
pilot yeah yeah it was a little weird
yeah and that whole thing with the
sovereign keeps coming back throughout
the movie and they keep touching on that
idea with rocket like that's what
bothered me throughout the movie was
that I kept feeling like they wanted to
use this battery thing to prove a point
or to make something out of it and all
that really comes out of that entire
conflict is just they keep going like ah
rocket you you just had to because
you've got the earth yeah and it's not
good enough after a while when that
subplot just starts so busted in every
few every twenty minutes isn't because
there's a lack of consequences I feel
like characters are aware of yeah that
bothered me and and like comedy moments
are just out of place like okay if
you're gonna amp up Drax's sex jokes
okay that's fine whatever but I did get
to a point where I'm like Jax is a
little too mean for me
like the way he talks to mantis and
stuff it's like while it's I guess
technically in character I'm like at
this point I feel like Jax should be a
little bit more aware if if he has a
moment during crazy danger scene in the
beginning where he's learned what
sarcasm because apparently Drax has
learned sarcasm yeah which seem to add a
character to me when when rocket was
like you're not ever supposed to tell
star-lord that he that we stole the
batteries and he's like
right I don't know what happened that's
a mystery to me that's a that seemed
like added character with the whole how
Drax is always honest and sincere and
doesn't understand sarcasm and all that
stuff yeah so apparently he's learned
sarcasm you would think you would learn
when he's being way too offensive
there's some people like mantis for
example I would have had a big tract
he's learning these North yes that could
have been a character if you can
actually give him he's he's trying to
learn language you know yes he'd read
like I was I was bummed about that cuz
Drax in the first movie is the comedy of
Drax is a fish out of water comedy the
absolute he doesn't have these social
cues that we all understand and that's
funny in this movie I feel like he's
just situation comedy he's just like
whatever situation to get him in it
seems like the motifs is the mode is to
go what's a drag job for this situation
how about this situation well he's gonna
call her really ugly because that's
unexpected you know yeah and so but then
sometimes within but I'll admit that
joke at the end did work wouldn't you
and he said like when he tells manulis
your work is a good call back yeah
there's stuff that he says that is
really good other moments that are very
because even that scene in the trailer
that everyone cracks up at when mantis
reads star-lords emotions and he starts
laughing watching the scene in the movie
was still really funny like that was
that was still a really funny scene for
Drax
but Durex is kind of pointless in terms
of helping serve the Guardians as a unit
or advance their mission I thought it
was cool that they paired him up with
mantis I thought that was a thing that
could work well because her whole thing
is that she consents and and you know
take on your emotions well the other
thing with those two is they're honest
yeah I thought that was such an
opportunity that that kind of works
sometimes and then other times just
becomes this weird yawn for jokes a lot
I felt like they lost the emotional side
of Drax which is part of what made the
balance of Drax work so well in the
first one because he seemed like a whole
character yeah because like they have
like one moment where he's kind of
reflecting on his daughter which they
turned into a joke scene to be said in
Drax is like a couple of things I could
think of that are so brief that where he
serves a purpose
in terms of publics this is the firt and
them and in the opening when he fights
to the squid and thingy and he flies
into the mouth that really cool shot it
was a funny moment where he thinks he
took down the monster but he really
didn't do it even more
yeah yeah that was that was funny and I
got the two moments I could think of
where he's does serve a purpose is when
he they at one point he's hanging
outside of the ship where Drax is
apparently just completely
indestructible at this point is like
getting whacked by the trees and
somebody shoots down the ship and when
he helps carry mantas up outside when
and the finale yeah you know thank you
but that's about it throughout the rest
of the film Drax seems like he's just
used for comedic purposes to be to say
funny stuff and but let's get into some
like spoilers that people probably
really want us to hear us talk about
yeah ego I like I really like I said my
non-spoiler I love Kurt Russell's
performance I thought I got a Kurt
Russell's performance is really good
there are some moments with ego that
seem a little bit off to me I think of a
really questionable scene for a lot of
people was when star-lord
hey that scene when star-lord treats the
light the ball the ball of light it was
a little bit like whoa you picked up on
that power without ya any practice
montage no frustration yeah you just
know that you could do this and you did
it was so quick and then they have this
motor suit yeah they have the moment
where they're you know playing catch
with each other which I think would have
worked because because there's a scene
that's for kind of foreshadowing that
moment where star-lord and Gomorrah are
talking to each other about how
star-lord just wanted a daddy was
jealous of other kids who were able to
play catch with their dads I think that
scene would have worked if star-lord had
mentioned something along those lines to
ego himself but he go wasn't around for
that moment when starter was talking
about his jealousy towards not having
that so when they're throwing the ball
back and forth it was a cute moment it
was a funny moment I thought it got a
little too stretched out when that's
their full-on playing catch in their
life
hey a moment that I wasn't
sure what to do with because I feel like
if the rest of the movie around it was
more solid that might have worked just
for ya cuz I don't know to me I didn't
really think they needed an extra scene
because it's like playing catch with
your son is such a ubiquitous concept
that when they started doing and I was
like oh yeah yeah that's cute he's he's
finally getting to do this but they
stretched it out but yeah it out and and
I was laughing at the time but yeah just
with the rest of the movie around it
does feel like another moment where I'm
like yeah I would have trimmed this down
or something like I don't get why you
lingered on this for so long because I
don't see an extra purpose beyond it oh
this is wacky a little bit and I thought
ego the the play not just Kurt Russell
but the whole plan I thought was really
cool the designs were cool the world was
cool I liked how they were questionable
about ego but when they get to the
planet and everyone who joined go on
that trip is starting to enjoy and be
fascinated and know and a wonder of it
all and was bringing some of that back
for me that's the thing I think is
actually pretty cool about this I like
the way they pitched the should we trust
you or not yeah kind of vibe because
they developed that over time and I
thought that was a nice thing they took
their time because in the comics ego is
a villain I wasn't aware of that before
watching this film neither was i I was I
wasn't aware of that so I thought it was
having really well because the the phone
sold me that he goes a good guy and you
wanna like Kurt Russell yeah like you
want you want you and and and and you
really care about star-lord because a
big part of the first one is he doesn't
know who his dad is and there's a big
mystery left up to who his father is and
then hear it you know there's touching
moments I like I like the chemistry
between Chris Pratt and Kurt Russell I
thought they worked really well together
I believe then as father and son would
this a huge distance and gap and I could
feel Kurt Russell I loved the lair he
provided a really you know wanting a son
and really wanting star-lord to be in
his life and work with him and all those
things
oh yeah and finding finally finding his
child that has the power to you know and
Starla has always been a lost wanderer
and he's finding his purpose now than
that that was all very effective here's
where the film it's really started to
lose me in the finale though you see I
like the reveal when Kurt Russell is
giving a speech you start learning
egos really up to how apparently he just
wants to take over the whole universe
and it could make sense you've been
around for millions of years you have
all these and unstoppable powers okay I
can be on board with that Kurt Russell's
performance is really good there and
when ego I don't know I mean I have an
ego reveals to star-lord that he killed
his mom
I thought the response was appropriate
where star-lord just whips out start
shooting idea that was appropriate it
was funny when David Hasselhoff appeared
that was like that that's like a good
Gardens of the galaxy joke to me a
serious moment you're taking very
serious it's intense and you get this
unexpected rewarding really funny joke
we have so half a beer here was
something about your character to know
next a what but it makes sense yeah it
makes sense way because it's in context
of the characters yeah you know like um
it sees in the film that has you planted
the non-spoiler without really revealing
it um was how you kind of don't see Kurt
Russell anymore you just see you know a
lot of destruction egos going to go
supervillain territory where it's just
hell bent on you know all the things
he's hell-bent on yeah and it just
becomes it becomes cliche that's just
the bottom line it stops cuz that's
that's what what that did leave a sour
taste in my mouth yeah because you meet
ego and Kurt Russell brings a lot to it
like he's not just hanging out like he
there are some moments where he's really
affecting and then when it finally when
the when the when it finally comes to a
head and we find out what his plan is
why he's got star-lord with him all that
stuff all that new ones just disappears
and then it's just like ah I gotta kill
you now and I think a lot of it is false
on the way the writing was handled with
star-lord you know cuz okay star-lord
shifting shooting his dad at first made
perfect sense to me in the moment what
did it make sense to me was how the
whole finale progressed was in terms of
star Laura's perspective and even after
the finale with the big action scenes
were done how stuff like I I felt like
okay if you couldn't include this in any
of the crazy action scenes you could
have at least included this in after all
action was done and they're flying off
into safety I thought you could have had
one scene where star-lords talking with
Gamora about my whole life I wanted to
know my dad I learned who my dad is
I'm bonding with him I learned about
these gifts that I have I you know like
he cuz he was truly having a real bond
and loving his father and having this
hope in this new future so is like the
day star-lord has in this movie is a big
day he he meets his father for the first
time was a huge part of his life he
learns about an entirely different side
of who he is and then all that stuff is
taken away like yeah just as soon as it
popped up and that's got to do something
to your carrot yeah there's no sense of
remorse or hurt we don't get to spend
time with him in the aftermath which is
which David the arm will know that you
are problems dad for this but but it's
if you want us to care about these
characters give us that yeah that's what
I mean by the details of the characters
responding to things though then it
should have been a feeling if the words
not guilt of having to kill this guy
because you realize he really is hell
bent on evil there should have been a
feeling of hurt or disappointment or
something and Starlin said it said star
loads whole arc is he realizes yondu
wasn't really all that bad of a guy
this one was just a mixed bag to me cuz
that really bothered me that he wasn't
affected by that will work for me was
yondu's growth and the relationship that
star-lord eventually ends on with him
you know seriously like this movie does
feel like it belongs to yondu cuz yondu
gets everything yondu gets some comedy
he gets character moments he gets the
challenges he has to step up yondu is
the person who steps up and makes the
sacrifice in this movie because the
whole moment were yondu he gives and i
like the whole like what is his
spacesuit design I got a camera that's
in the first one actually but I like
like a bubble wrap yeah yeah the whole
bubble wrap spacesuit thing that was a
great moment where he gives him the
spaceship this this spacesuit and then
yondu's sacrifices himself to save
star-lord and in beautiful moment yeah
and they had great you know like and
because in a way it's one of those
sequels in terms of yondu where it it
will probably enhance the experience of
watching you on doing the first one
because they didn't can anything from
the first one they made all those things
work how like yondu said he would eat
him and house are like new laughs at him
and the move in this one because he's
because he's like you believe me a joke
it was a joke okay yeah like you would
have never really done that you see how
yondu was really protecting star-lord
because he saw that ego is you know like
loves to have sex well that's that is a
cool thing about this movies you get to
through kind of through Peter quill but
also especially through yonder you get
to watch these guys who have to think
about maintaining status and being tough
but who are also carry on inside you
know who aren't just Ravagers you know a
new gets the redemption moment you know
and we'll touch on Stallone scene in a
second but when you know all the
Ravagers show up and they're gonna be
doing the fireworks I started to cry the
inner Liz beautiful yeah the funeral
wasn't a very it was a very effective
scene I wasn't crying there but when the
Ravagers showed up I started crying cuz
I'm like this is it yondu gets his
relationship with star-lord it has the
resolution with him and the Ravagers
love and respect him again I would never
watched the end of Fast and the Furious
7 like a couple days ago and and washing
the end of guardians to was like I felt
like Michael Rooker really died yeah
like this was beautiful name of a great
and that's a weird thing like that is a
huge positive about this movie for me is
like all that young you just have left
an impact on me like they made a
sacrifice I don't know if though retcon
everything and bring him back or
whatever that character died I was sad
about it and like he's okay great and
going back to an earlier point about
Rocket Raccoon yeah when the mood when
yondu died one of my first thoughts went
back to Rocket yeah which was if Rocket
didn't steal the batteries hey okay yeah
the batteries helped in and blowing up
the brain sure but at the same time
though I felt like they could have been
because when they when they were
like this in the finale when they first
go into the you know [ __ ] when they
first go into egos brain the mantis is
able to just easily put ego to sleep and
they could have figured out a way to
destroy he goes brain yeah you know they
would have had the time to do it
yeah but beak and when they were
shooting it up and just know they were
destroying it they were making an impact
on it but then when the gold of the
sovereign people showed up because
Rockets stole some batteries that messed
up the entire plan the entire process
and they probably could have destroyed
ego and gotten off the planet if rocket
didn't steal those battery he's really
weird like it's just a really weird
actually have consequences subplot and
but he doesn't but rocky doesn't feel
the consequences this thing of a man he
really bonded with yeah and and and they
do that thing where they bother to go
all these ships are unmanned they're
they're piloted remotely so they just
destroy all these ships in mass yeah and
then go about their damage feels like
this thing that keeps barging into the
movie oh yeah yeah I mean like when the
sovereign people first showed up and
egos brain I thought I thought it was
gonna do a route that I would have been
okay with I probably would have actually
preferred it even though I would have
found it a little predictable
I would have preferred what if they went
this way which was they kind of learn
what's going on here okay and destroy
ego who do you know yeah but instead no
they're just bad guys after they helped
destroy ego then they can go also still
for stealing our batteries we gotta have
a tell me out of this yeah exactly
you know or in light of what they were
used for you know we'll let this one
slide or something but but yeah they
just not show up to also fight and yeah
it just makes everything kind of mess
it's not like a mess you know and these
are like specific details that were
talking on that of what led to the
disappointment of the film for me and
and especially the comedy moments
they're like touching off for some of it
I remember exactly when I thought the
comedy in here reminds me of men and
black okay hey when we started getting
like sex jokes like more like more
vulgar jokes in the first one because
I'm like that's a man in black two did
the vulgarity because they're probably
running low on some truly witty comedy
material right now
yeah and that's and that's in James
Gunn's wheelhouse and that's something
Marvel is probably at least giving him
the flexibility to bring in to flesh out
their universe and make a difference
well the scene though that really really
showed what I knew this movie was
failing on a lot of the comedy for me
there's this moment because we're yondu
takes over to kind of the rear position
with Ravagers and then she wants to get
a ship she's talking to Sean Gunn and
wants to ship cuz she's like I want it
then she starts coming they have this
show we're slowly panning in on her
she's giving her what her mission
speeches nebula nebulas are yeah where
nebula is giving her their speech about
her I'm going to have vengeance on
Gamora and I'm gonna kill thanos since
this long speech a little bit into the
speech I was thinking oh there's a punch
line coming yeah there's there's gonna
be an obvious punch line probably from
Sean Gunn right when she's done talking
where the music's gonna cut off and then
he's gonna say something that's supposed
to be funny
yeah the first movie had not a single
moment like that the first movie
probably would have handled it in a way
where I'm believing nebulous speech and
I'm feeling the moment and I didn't see
that joke from Sean Gunn coming yeah it
was and then in this packed theater that
was initially having a good time Sean
Gunn makes a joke says more funny stuff
no one left no one not a single laughter
and then the whole audience it was that
exact scene where I was like here's or
the comedy is failing for me and a lot
of comedy moments just don't hit where
they're like like clearly often like not
just like a throwaway joke where it's
okay that no one laughed at that you
know like when the sovereigns meet yondu
with the rolling out the carpet and then
it stops and they have a problem like hi
hi we didn't see that coming I guess but
it just doesn't kind of fit in that
moment
well yeah it's that thing of like I get
this joke and this joke is also gonna
take its time and it's not a fresh joke
anymore ya know I've already seen this
joke happen and that
happens more than once and also just
just sidebar shouts out to Sean gun cuz
I'd like he's really I just have like
he's just him as if just profess
performance I thought was surprisingly
good and he had one of the funniest like
he had the best post-credit scene to me
yeah this post-credit scene where he's
trying to figure out how to use the
arrow and the whole time we're thinking
like oh shoot he's gonna hit himself
he's gonna hit the ends of a stabbing
tracks it was really funny that was a
hysterical scene actually and I like how
they they didn't put so much emphasis on
him but they put just enough to the
point where the mantle of the arrow
being passed down to him made enough
sense to me if she was the does he know
he hasn't seen where he sides against
yondu but then eventually he goes back
to yondu and helps him escape from the
prison and all that stuff he gives him
back his arrow gives him back the
prototype of the afin and so he earned
says he earned he earned that spot I
felt for it to be more part of the
guardians of the galaxy maybe even an
infinity war I don't know oh well I got
something I would like to see and that's
something that was a a high yeah for
sure and still longs you know he
probably had a two days of shooting
lesson ova all that talk about who
Stallone playing and he literally
probably only had a couple of days of
shooting and his scene though with yondu
where you're learning oh this is yondu's
past he comes from the Ravagers and
there was a code and that's all these
like really important things and and
it's the loans character feels betrayed
by yondu I feel like technically still
in did a good job
I felt though that like a the characters
not really involved in the film so if
you're gonna use the loan I feel like
give them something that's a lot more I
don't know prominent or definitive and I
mean when you see the post-credits scene
it makes it more special I guess he's
like oh this is more referencing the og
guardians of the galaxy yes it's one of
those things where he shows up and
you're like ah I bet he'll be bigger in
the future like hopefully hopefully ie
why they would do that sting if they
weren't unless they're just like this is
happening in the universe no they're not
gonna see it I mean they talked about
like Kevin Feige and I think James Gunn
they were like it was more just a fun
thing for the Marvel fans we don't
know if we're gonna be actually involved
in the perk in the future stuff there
you go yeah but seen Stallone doats ô
those do i I couldn't get fully invested
in that scene I just really couldn't get
in best events I was very distracted
that this is Sylvester Stallone yeah
because Stallone while he has an
occasional movie work most of the time
especially I'm showing up in a Guardians
movie being a very serious role not even
like a fun role he's a serious character
I had a hard time truly just being
invested in that moment I was I was more
distracted than drawn to that scene I
feel like you could have gone what I
really could have gone with a known
actor but maybe not someone as famous or
as spoofed or parodied as someone like
Stallone you know yeah I'll meet you
halfway on that like during that scene I
was very much like oh yeah yeah but I
still thought it was kind of cool to see
him there and I liked the idea at least
of him and Michael Rooker sharing a
scene together you even know it isn't I
mean what I think about it a big moment
I think what everyone really wanted was
the scene with Kurt Russell and Stallone
that one in real tango week yeah I'm
just really quick I did like that they
finally gave Gamora something else to do
because I'm getting kind of tired of the
the dynamic of like oh you know male
lead and female lead are they gonna get
together is there romance there like I'm
to be honest I'm a bit tired of that
plotline and so like when they spiraled
her off with nebula and gave the sisters
a story yeah that was really cool I mean
oh yeah we've primarily talked about our
issues with the film yeah whatever you
got to do that noise we're not it's okay
it's family friend yeah if you and speak
like one of the one of the positives I
thought I did like well I'm not a huge
fan of the actresses performance of
nebula I mean I think she does a good a
good enough job
I like the relationship that develops
with nebula
and Gomorrah I like how yeah I cried I
teared up when Gomorrah goes to hugger
at the end and yeah and nebulas not sure
how to respond yeah no I actually teared
up cuz this whole movie they haven't
gotten along at all oh yeah and they
don't have the thickest conversations
but the conversations they have I like
yeah what they were talking about I like
the issues they were confronting in
their relationship and I like the
tension of not exactly knowing what to
think of nebula in these scenes should
we believe her like those those moments
those those recurring motifs in the
movie takes time to build upon are we
supposed to trust ego or you know
doesn't it be able to have a point here
or is she conniving like those things
are I know were pretty cool narrative
yes she became like what they do on
doing nebula to characters who were
antagonists in the first one they they
have them and NAT they have them grow in
a in a natural way where you see another
layer to them that feels authentic feels
organic it doesn't feel like they're
just trying to make these guys good
characters now to keep them around for a
franchise or something yeah young babies
that know what but nebula especially and
I love the touches of actually hearing
real specifics on wine emulates Gamora
because then the first one is just more
like that us shows up Gabor was my
favorite daughter here you're like I
really get why nebula hates the more I
get I mean you know it's that whole
she's a robot because Gamora constantly
beat her yeah every time you beat me dad
took off one of my my limbs and replace
that with a robot chin not that stuff
and replaced it with robot pieces and
and that's messed up like in that that
made me feel again like that was a movie
made me feel yes I mean I really
understand was just like nebula put your
ego down it's like I actually really
understand why you hate Gamora so why
all your hate for your dad has been
transferred over into Gamora as well
yeah and there's an easy place for
movies like these to stumble and I and I
appreciate that they made a bigger
choice
choice that you can't just meet with it
come on drop it like yeah thing yeah you
know Oh real quick going off of a point
you were making earlier in terms of like
the whole will they won't they thing
with Gomorrah and sorrow or this one I
you could totally follow me on this
anyone eat in the comments you could
totally fault me for saying I'm being
nitpicky about this however I will still
are you and I don't
I think the first Guardian script would
have thought about this a little bit
yeah if you do the math start with Peter
quill it's like eight or nine or some
he's not he's not even ten I think they
like it looks like a ten-year-old buddy
I don't think he is because you do the
math of how this movie starts off in
nineteen eighty and they still haven't
had a child yet ego and Peter's mom and
then I think the first one takes place
in like 88 in the beginning or 89 some
bits in the eighties obviously yeah he's
a little kid he's no he's definitely not
alone
yeah no kid would be aware of certain
yes so when some when all the TV shows a
star Lords listing off in this movie I'm
like okay maybe he happened to really
absorb all these shows and all his time
in space allowed him to not forget about
this or maybe he tracked down reruns
somehow something like it's a big
universe yeah but when he's talking
about ratings and the way TV shows work
and the will they won't they stuff like
the format of sitcoms I was like you
weren't around with what 9 year old
would absorb this piece of information
and study sitcoms to this degree and
then have readily available with that
information in the it's not like that
the the TV analysis and commentary
industry was not what it is now because
I'm like okay that's fine that the
script is willing to make fun of that
it's just as a detail nitpick like I
just didn't buy that this little kid
would have picked up all this
information yes it's like you
and they remind you of his back sorry
you're like he spend a lot of time on a
Ravager ship being afraid he was gonna
be eaten I don't like he does return to
Earth and just chill down yeah yeah so
yeah like there there are details that
do pull you out and make you go that's
that's that I can see your script yeah I
can see that's the thing I know that's
why I would compare a lot of the comedy
to men and black - yeah as it was like I
feel the script yeah
it doesn't coalesce quite the right way
and it's I don't know it's it's a
strange movie because of all this
because it's perplexing to me because
the first movie I felt had a really nice
grip on its tone and it pitched
everything in the right level and this
movie pitches some things the right
level and some things just feel really
slippery it hatches it's a super mixed
bag yondu was the only thing that was
like perfectly handled or me yeah cool
plot is great every time we're focused
on that guy it's great also just shouts
out to the woman who played mantis
because I did like that character I
liked her characterization I liked what
she brought to it I liked having a new
character around and again I I wish her
scenes were better or than the script
you brought up at actually a good point
about her I still question why she was
there and that was the point that I
didn't even think about when you brought
it up I was like yeah they are just here
to keep this guy's sleep that's the only
reason ego has let you in on his whole
world and plan and everything I got
everything when your whole thing is
feeling side I just feel like if you
spent all this time with him things that
might have been different
yeah like they talked about a thing with
feelings that's not really utilized to
help serve the plot other than a couple
of like an interesting scene yeah and a
funny scene but I don't know if the
comics have her in there because she
helps ego fall asleep but I kind of
pulled me out thinking wait a minute
wait a minute this ego guy has the
powers of everything he's God he's God
he is God but he can't fall asleep I
guess is one thing that he hates
troubles with
and he just finds this one birthing this
or a whole purpose in the movie is to
help ego it did pull me out a little bit
like Oh needs to shut up I wish make
sense but I just wish they maybe had
touched it differently because half of
my brain goes well I I couldn't fathom
it but the problem is the movie leaves
you to figure it out all on your own so
so half your brain goes what do you
can't fall see yeah really
and the other half goes well maybe he
just got so much in his mind and so much
energy and so many things to think about
that yeah he needs help I could see it
it's just they never bother with the
characters enough to tell you yeah and
so then you're left to wonder yeah like
why is she just hanging out in this
planet it doesn't seem like a very good
so I mean it's like there's good and bad
in almost everything we talked about
every complaint that we have usually
initiated with something good the film
was doing yeah and everything and a lot
of things that were bad sometimes turn
into something good like it's such it's
it is so mum so oh and that's another
joke that just like okay
rocket laughing about taser face in
context with the character that the
scene makes sense I like how the
Ravagers all-star laughing at him is not
a good name I really had a place point
for me in the film was when the
sovereign is talking with the burning
Ravagers and taser face is all messed up
and then the sovereign asks what's your
name
taser face and then and then sovereign
starts cracking up and I was when I was
in that scene I was thinking okay I
don't really know these gold people but
I do know they wouldn't laugh in this
particular moment it wasn't even like
like a left here it was like I have the
gold person or in his draft and and that
just leaves you tooling I feel like that
moment could have worked with a
different character because now I'm just
wondering about the rules I'm like do
the sovereign have tasers they know what
you know is that in character for her
just a little crack up at this random
literally about to die yeah it's just a
strange moment that doesn't have enough
around it to not make me just get
distracted and start thinking about yeah
works you know and that's where nitpicks
come from I guess but the thing is that
what makes the first one so special is
those little moments yeah it was pulled
me out you know like I think about like
one of the little details of Guardians
one that I love so much is the prison
breakout scene where they all have very
specific tasks of what to do in the
scenes intense and exciting and they're
cutting back and forth to all this
action in the film takes a moment to
just stop and star lore standing across
from the guy with the peg leg and and
it's quiet and the guy just goes you
need my side like that's a great
illustration of like those details
rais'd yeah perfect little detail
touches or or heart-aching sweet moments
like when when they're all deciding like
should they die going after Ronan and
they all start standing up and Rockets
like all right ah Minnie and then he
goes are you happy I'm standing no we're
all standing like a bunch of jackasses
like that's a great mo like they hear
the comedy just it's either you see a
joke coming or the joke doesn't work
often but yeah it's it's a super it's a
super Mick City bagga-t for me I just
don't think they approached it from part
of these characters go next I feel like
they approached it from like okay what
do we give everybody what do we give
this fan cuz like the ikan of the
villain problem in Marvel movies I would
have said they nailed it solved it if
they handle the finale woody go better
if they had everything with ego before
that perfect and I it was great cuz it
visits you with the nuanced problem of
like this guy's been around for so long
and he's seen so much that he's he's
just like yeah it's all me and I'm gonna
reshape the universe in my image because
I've lived so long nothing is
significant blah blah blah and then it
just becomes the same thing we've seen a
bunch of times lately which is human
beings are disappointing and some of
their life so I'm just gonna reshape it
I'm just gonna kill it yeah and are
those evil now oh yeah
and the thing is like what happened to
the layers he wants his son he wants him
to work with him I feel like a character
who's that old and that wise when
star-lord is not down I don't think he
would just immediately go well I gotta
kill you
the most extreme way possible it just I
feel like you'd be Trey's that character
and then it makes it worse it's like
yeah you had this great setup you've got
a good actor who showed up to do this
and then when it comes time for the
climax to start he's just another big
all-powerful bad guy we have to shoot a
lot hand and oh there's there was one
another positive thing I want to touch
on I like what they're doing with Stan
Lee I don't like how is it how he's like
with the Watchers please see what the
post-credits scene doesn't establish
that he's part of the Watchers because
they start leaving and he goes you're my
ride home yeah so we don't know like
what he was doing there with the
Watchers but I like how they're they're
building up that we're probably gonna
find out who Stan Lee's been this whole
time in the continuity now Stan Lee is
the same Stan Lee in every single movie
even when he was Hugh Hefner yeah
exactly it wasn't Hugh Hefner yeah he
was somebody's just mr. Hefner as he
walks down the walk I think Tony just
mistakes him for Hugh oh is that well
you had some on the back end goes hey
half for something it turns is like oh
it's not good after Stan Lee okay all
right that makes sense no your marvel
well that's but that's a debate he was
still like now in context he might not
be if you haven't her but at the time
who's is Hugh Hefner to me yeah baby
yeah that's sure we all let the way to
find out than ever yeah I got anything
family is 120 and Marvel's in their 45th
film I think we're finally gonna find
out who stay awake they'll finally make
a movie starring so should have started
milking this a long time
not now it goes Stanley's like
approaching 100 anyway yeah I mean don't
get me wrong are non-spoiler review
probably wouldn't upset as many people
as I'm sure there's gonna be a lot of
Marvel fanboys who are commenting saying
like oh you guys are just you know
talking crap the whole time
well hey you know honestly I know I know
we're not the only ones who were
disappointed and in order to explain
that because when you talk a non-spoiler
one it's hard to explain why you're
disappointed with the spoiler it's like
we're gonna take the time to thoroughly
explain you so you understand yeah well
the other thing about that is just like
I know a lot of people who've seen it
who else most people I know have seen
this movie are very enthusiastic about
it however I don't think I've heard one
person not include it's not as good as
the person yeah like everybody I know
even the people were like oh I was so
awesome or still a first ones better but
you know yeah so there's plenty of enjoy
ability to still be had and I said skip
it you know yeah and the thing is at
least on on my terms I still had a
really fun time yeah I still had a good
time watching this movie I think you'll
still enjoy yourself there's still stuff
that words expect yes Tony thanks goes
from it was really cool yeah it's
hilarious great stuff there's there's in
between because it's not like a solid
like Oh first half is great second half
as bad it's like it's all in between
yes keeps fluctuating from great to not
so good anyway yeah there's no spoiler
review
happy to have some of you agree and
happy to have a lot of you get mad at us
subscribe to the real rejects pre this
is Jerry on Twitter and Instagram social
media manager or blum blum house and the
real rejects yeah just got a patreon go
check out all the exclusive content on
there and all the awesome rewards we got
obadiah uncensored video content
uncensored and I wonder if YouTube will
cause this to be in restricted mode by
just doing this one motion well you know
we got to test all the boundaries and we
got to test all the boundaries is this
restricted is this restricted
what about this